Speaker 1: Now that we have a larger sample
size, we can talk about what is not just something
they'll try maybe, but what is clearly the
new electoral strategy to the extent that
we can even call it a strategy from the modern
Republican Party.
And that strategy or maybe the right word
for it would be more of a tactic is to call
an election rigged to say that there was fraud
before we actually even know the results.
We started to see this with Donald Trump months
before the 2012 presidential election.
And of course, it has become essentially the
story told by Republicans about the 2020 election.
It was rigged.
It was fraud, mail in ballots, massive dumps
of ballots.
We need forensic audits.
There were bamboo fibers.
There was too much barbecue sauce on the papers.
There was not enough.
OK, maybe not that last one.
But you get the point.
This is the story.
It's the election wasn't fair.
Trump should be president.
That's the story being told by the right.
And then we saw the exact same thing with
Larry Elder in advance of this week's California
gubernatorial recall.
Let's go.
I know I've played these clips already this
week, but let's go to Larry Elder being asked
by Jacob Soboroff.
Will you commit to accepting the results of
this election?
This was the day before the recall.
Speaker 2: Again, whether or not you win or
lose, will you accept the results of the election
tomorrow?
I think we all ought to be looking at election
integrity, no matter whether you're a Democrat
and independent or Republican.
Let's all make sure that the election is a
fair election.
So this all work together, no matter what
the results are, to make sure that the results
are valid and legitimate.
And everybody who voted should have voted.
Let's all do that together.
Is that a commitment to accept the election
tomorrow?
I'll do that together.
Let's all work together on both sides of the
aisle to make sure that the election is a
fair election.
Speaker 1: We know that's very familiar, very
familiar for a reason.
And then also here was Donald Trump doing
the same thing on Newsmax an extra week earlier
as well.
Got the recall
Speaker 2: election coming up in less than
a week.
It's actually happening as we speak.
The polls appear to show
Speaker 1: Newsom looks safer at this point.
Larry Elder is the man that could take it
from him.
What do you think happens in California?
Speaker 3: Well, it's probably they're sending
out all ballots.
All the ballots are, you know, mail out mail
in ballots.
In fact, I guess you even have a case where
you can make your own ballot.
When that happens, nobody's going to win except
these Democrats.
So, you know, look, they're very good.
The one thing they're good at is rigging elections.
So I predict it's a rigged election.
Let's see how it turns out.
Speaker 1: So this is now a strategy and none
of this is surprising.
There is a very good Washington Post article
about this.
Former President Trump false voter fraud claims
found new life in California's biggest election
this year.
The top Republicans seeking to replace Governor
Gavin Newsom in Tuesday's recall declined
before the election to say whether he would
accept the results.
A website affiliated with his campaign invites
visitors to sign a petition to stop the fraud
of the California recall election.
And a previous version of the site, published
before the election took place, blamed voter
fraud for Newsom being, quote, reinstated
as governor.
Now, it's funny to even say reinstated.
He was never removed of.
The article goes on to explain.
Of course, there is no evidence for these
claims, which have nonetheless been amplified
repeatedly by Trump.
But their arrival in the country's largest
blue state offered proof of their currency
within the Republican Party, where some leaders
have increasingly sought to undermine public
confidence in Democratic victories.
That's an understatement by baselessly alleging
that elections are vulnerable to manipulation.
It does mention, with Newsom projected to
defeat the recall, elder conceded the race
early Wednesday morning, telling his audience
to be gracious in defeat.
But the campaign tactics leading up to the
vote, including open threats to raise doubts
about the results in case of defeat, suggests
the possibility of a new normal, where Republicans
challenge election losses even in heavily
Democratic states without proof of serious
fraud or rule breaking.
This is going to be the strategy now.
None of it should surprise us.
It is no one straight out of Trump's playbook.
Elder is essentially a Trump clone, agreeing
with Trump on just about everything.
If a Republican wins the election, then we
can trust the results.
Everything is as it should be.
No fraud took place.
If they lose, then it's rigged.
And this is going to be, I believe, their
M.O. from here on out.
And not only is this concerning because it
is the next step in Republicans completely
abandoning, trying to win on issues.
I'm not going to give you the whole story
that Noam Chomsky and I discussed of how this
came.
To be because it goes all the way back to
the civil rights movement and and that era,
but recently, at least as recent history is
concerned, as far as recent history is concerned,
we saw, particularly in the Obama era and
obviously when Trump ran, Trump pretended
to be about policy when he ran, although they
were all completely unrealistic policy promises
based on misstatements about the world.
Right.
A completely bogus promise to build a wall
across the entire southern border with Mexico
that Mexico would pay for based on lies about
the immigration situation.
So the framework was lies and the proposed
solution was never going to happen.
He was never going to build that wall.
Mexico was never going to pay for it.
But it was like pretending to be about policy
to the 2020 election, not even pretending
to be about policy.
That's Marjorie Taylor Green, that's Madison
Cawthorn, that's Lauren Bobert.
They don't even pretend to be about policy.
And then the next step is, despite not actually
doing policy or campaigning on policy, when
you lose, you say that it was rigged.
This is very authoritarian.
It is very authoritarian, and it's a very
dangerous new status quo, if that's indeed
what is what it's going to be.
And you know what the signal was that they
were going to do it.
In 2016, Trump
Speaker 3: won
Speaker 1: electorally and still didn't accept
the results of the popular vote.
Remember, he said Hillary Clinton didn't even
really win the popular vote.
She won because of millions of illegal immigrants
that voted and or, you know, people from Massachusetts
were being bused up to New Hampshire to vote,
of course, ignoring the fact that none of
those Massachusetts people would be registered
to vote in New Hampshire.
They wouldn't be able to vote in New Hampshire.
But every election now is going to be fraudulent
until and unless they're start to be consequences
for telling that lie time after time after
time.
And it is I don't think I have to explain
this to you, but there's also the it's not
even a hypocrisy.
It's sort of like a conflict between they
claim that, I guess the Democratic Party,
although think about the number of people
that would need to be involved, they claim
the Democratic Party is smart enough to manufacture
millions of fraudulent votes and get away
with it.
But they don't actually put the votes in places
where it would have a bigger effect on the
race.
Like, it just none of it makes sense.
And with regard to Trump, there's one other
aspect to this.
Narcissists can't admit to being wrong.
So when the polling data started to show Trump's
going to lose, Elder is going to lose, particularly
with Elder, recently they started the campaign.
Well, if they win, it's because they've stolen
it.
If they win, it's because it's rigged, because
they can't just say we just we were just wrong.
California didn't want to remove Gavin Newsom.
We miscalculated.
We were wrong.
They have to go to it was actually fraud.
And then maybe the most insidious and scary
part, which maybe they're not competent enough
for, is that this could end up being part
of a cry wolf strategy, claim that there's
fraud when there isn't in a whole bunch of
races where they lose, then they commit the
fraud in some future election.
And then when Democrats say, guys, there was
real fraud here, then they brush it off and
they say, guys, we everybody's sick of these
claims of fraud.
Just accept that these are the results.
I hope that that doesn't happen because they're
not organized enough to do it.
But that's a scary aspect of
this as well.